voilà pour les préoccupations
quotidiennes du gouvernement pour
l'avenir pour un futur plus lointain il
y à la recherche la recherche et le
colloque qui se tient depuis ce matin et
pendant quatre jours au palais des
congrès de paris a été entouré dans sa
préparation d'un luxe de moyens c'est
françois mitterrand lui-même qui l'a
inauguré cet après-midi 3500 chercheurs
qui viennent donner leurs idées une
demande énorme du public pour résoudre
des cas concrets voici le portrait de ce
colloque dont l'objectif est précisé par
le chef de l'état nous souhaitons que de
leur côté les chercheurs les innovateurs
les techniciens soient conscients
pleinement conscient au delà même de
leur rôle de citoyen des grands
objectifs que le pays se donnent
aujourd'hui en tout cas ils sachent dans
quel sens nous travaillons pour sortir
de la crise
reconquérir le marché intérieur assurer
l'emploi réduire les inégalités
améliorer les conditions de travail
créer de nouvelles relations avec les
pays en voie de développement
toute préoccupation qui ne peuvent être
étrangers à ceux dont la mission est de
créer l'outil de l'avenir le relais pris
presque tous les membres du gouvernement
étaient là la recherche est donc devenu
un phénomène politique c'est sur ce
terrain que c'est d'ailleurs
effectivement placé
le ministre de la recherche jean pierre
chevènement l'essentiel est qu à travers
le débat
les forces de l'inertie et de la
résignation et reculées des
problématiques nouvelles ont surgi à la
faveur du contexte nouveau créé par la
victoire de la gauche et à travers les
réformes de structure nationalisation
décentralisation qu'elle a commencé
d'opérer